like controversial opinions are not
actually very controversial they're
they're shared by the vast majority of
people in this country
um that you shouldn't give kids uh uh
surgical interventions and
pharmaceutical interventions that might
have long lasting effects that women
don't deserve to lose their livelihoods
for being feminists that JK Rowling
doesn't deserve to have death and rate
threats sent to her
um that male prisoners shouldn't be
placed in the female estate that NHS
Wards should be women only
these are not controversial opinions but
um unfortunately we have a kind of a
middle class there that is captured by
all these you know absurd ideas
um
and uh you know it the the kind of False
Consensus they've created around these
issues uh comes about true intimidation
and Force and and canceling and so on